NEW YORK AND WE HOPE THE RED
WAVE TOUCHES THE EMPIRE STATE.
DESANTIS IS CRUISING TO VICTORY
IN FLORIDA.
NOT EVEN CLOSE ENOUGH TO PUT
THERE ON THE SCREEN IT'S A RUN
AWAY.
MOVE OVER TO MICHIGAN WHERE
TUDOR DIXON IS MAKING THIS A
RACE.
GRETCHEN WHITMER IS ONLY UP 4.
BUT THIS, AGAIN IS, LIKE NEW
YORK.
IT'S A TOTAL TOSS-UP.
GRETCHEN IS AN UNLIKEABLE LIAR
WITH A SCARY STARE AND SHE CAN'T
EVEN ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT
COVID.
LITERALLY SHE CANNOT ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
WATCH THIS.
>> I'M SORRY, [BLEEP] DID I DO
THAT WHEN I TOUCHED THE EAR
THING?
IT STARTED TO FALL OUT.
>> OH NO.
IT'S OKAY.
>> Jesse: SO BAD.
I CAN'T BELIEVE MY EAR PIECE DID
THAT.
LET'S TURN TO TUDOR DIXON.
SHE IS RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR IN
MICHIGAN.
HEY TUDOR, MICHIGAN BEHIND YOU
THERE.
>> YEAH WE ARE HAVING A RALLY
HERE.
THE ENERGY ON THE GROUND IS
GREAT.
[CHEERS]
>> THIS IS REALLY EXCITING
NIGHT.
I HEARD WHAT YOU SAID MICHIGAN 4
POINTS ALWAYS QUESTIONABLE.
WE FEEL IT.
WE REALLY EXPECT MICHIGAN TO GO
RED.
YOU CAN SEE THE EXCITEMENT
BEHIND ME.
AND PEOPLE ARE SICK OF GRETCHEN
WHITMER LYING CONVENIENT THAT
HER EAR PIECE WENT OUT.
>> Jesse: YOU GOT A GLENN
YOUNGKIN TYPE OF RED VEST THERE.
DID HE HAND THAT TO YOU
RECENTLY?
[LAUGHTER]
>> THIS IS A GIFT FROM GOVERNOR
YOUNGKIN, YES, IT IS.
SO I'M WEARING IT TONIGHT
BECAUSE I'M HOPING THAT IT IS
ALSO A LUCKY VEST.
>> Jesse: IT'S A TOSS-UP THERE.
ANYONE'S RACE.
IT'S GOING TO BE CLOSE.
WHAT'S YOUR CLOSING MESSAGE UP
IN MICHIGAN?
>> OUR MESSAGE IS PARENTS WANT
TO HAVE SOMEONE THAT IS GOING TO
STAND WITH THEM.
I MEAN, THIS IS WHY I'M WEARING
THIS VEST, BECAUSE IT IS VERY
SIMILAR TO GOVERNOR YOUNGKIN'S
MESSAGE.
WE HAVE HEARD THIS FROM
DEMOCRATS.
REPUBLICANS.
THEY BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
ABANDONED BY THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
THEY WANT PARENTS INVOLVED IN
EDUCATION.
BUT IT'S GONE EVEN A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER THAN WHAT WE SAW WITH
GOVERNOR YOUNGKIN BECAUSE NOW
PARENTS ARE SO UPSET ABOUT THIS
SEX AND GENDER THEORY IN
SCHOOLS.
THESE IMPORTANT GRAPHIC BOOKS.
AND THE DEMOCRATS HAVE MADE FUN
OF THEM.
YOU HAVE SEEN THIS THE ELITIST
DEMOCRATS ARE MAKING FUN OF
REPUBLICANS AND THEY ARE MAKING
FUN OF EVEN DEMOCRAT PARENTS WHO
ARE SAYING WE WANT A VOICE IN
EDUCATION.
THAT'S OUR BIGGEST MESSAGE.
MICHIGAN JUST NEEDS TO COME BACK
OVERALL.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
REDUCE CRIME.
WE SUPPORT OUR POLICE.
WE BRING BACK THE AMERICAN
DREAM.
MAKE IT EASIER TO DO BUSINESS.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS RESONATE
RIGHT NOW IN MICHIGAN.
>> Jesse: HOW BIG ARE FOOD
PRICES, GAS PRICES, IS THERE
STILL A DIAPER AND FORMULA
SHORTAGE SITUATION IN MICHIGAN?
>> YEAH, WE ARE STILL STRUGGLING
WITH FORMULA BUT GAS PRICES ARE
SOME OF THE HIGHEST IN THE
NATION SO THAT'S A BIG DEAL AND
GRETCHEN WHITMER HAD OPPORTUNITY
AFTER OPPORTUNITY TO REDUCE
TAXES, PERSONAL INCOME TAX, GIVE
A CHILD TAX CREDIT, RETIREMENT
TAX BUT ALSO GIVE A GAS TAX
HOLIDAY.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS VETOED WITH
NO EXCUSE.
THE PEOPLE OF MICHIGAN ARE
SAYING WE WANT A GOVERNOR THAT
IS GOING TO PUT MONEY BACK IN
OUR POCKETS AND TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY WHEN WE SEE INFLATION.
THEY COMPLETELY CONNECTED HER TO
JOE BIDEN.
SHE IS ALSO VERY ANTI-AMERICAN
ENERGY.
SO THE BIDEN-WHITMER POLICIES
ARE HITTING MICHIGAN HARD.
SHE WANTS TO SHUT DOWN OUR
PIPELINE AND THE PEOPLE OF
MICHIGAN ARE SAYING NO.
>> Jesse: MAYBE YOU CAN GIVE HER
A HOLIDAY AFTER TOMORROW.
TUDOR DIXON, EVERYBODY, RUNNING
FOR GOVERNOR IN MICHIGAN.
GOOD LUCK.
>> THANK YOU.
WE TELL HER SHE IS NONESSENTIA